(light music)
- So you wanna be a landlord?
Great. You're at the right spot.
Well, let me tell you, being
a landlord isn't an easy job
like fire fighting or being a governor.
Being a landlord takes training
and I'm here to give you the training
so you can succeed and get
the praise that you deserve.
When a new tenant is
putting down their deposit,
make sure they pay in a
money order, never a check.
Checks are too easy.
Money orders tiptoe the
line between ridiculous
and inconvenient, so they're perfect.
Now, before your tenant moves in,
make sure the apartment isn't at 100%.
You know, a wobbly knob
here, a leaky faucet there,
anything you can do
to make sure you get the security deposit,
or what we like to call
in the biz as free money.
Never answer a phone call from a tenant.
Whenever a tenant calls
you, they want two things.
They either want you to fix something
or they want to tell you something stupid
like there was just a burglary
and you don't need that
stress in your life.
The only time you should
speak to a tenant on the phone
is when you call them
up at 6 AM on a Saturday
to tell them, hey, in
two Wednesdays from now,
I'm shutting off the
water for maintenance.
Which brings me to my next step.
Every few months, just shut
the water off for maintenance.
What does maintenance mean?
I don't know, but the power
of telling your tenant
when they can and can't
shower is just incredible,
so use that power.
You also have the power of eviction.
Every once in a while,
knock on their door and say,
hey, you've been a little loud lately
or just ask if you can have a look around
because this is your
property, you control it.
Own that power.
After your tenant has been
in the unit for about a year,
hike the rent up by 200
dollars, just for funsies.
It'll throw them off an confuse them,
so you just did your job.
If your tenant decides to
leave your unit for elsewhere,
make sure to inspect that thing
for every little possible flaw.
You know, a wobbly knob
here, a leaky faucet there.
Anything to secure that free money
because that's the end game.
If you follow these steps,
I can guarantee you will feel fulfilled.
Remember, you are a landlord.
They expect you to be annoying,
inconvenient, and mysterious.
(light music)